الذكاء الاصطناعي باتا سلاحا ذو حدين فرغم
ان استخدامه قد يسهم في تحقيق نهضه على
المستويين العلمي وايضا على المستوى
الاقتصادي الا ان سلبياته بدات تتضح تباعا
وصلت حتى تهديد بقاء الجنس البشري اخر هذه
المخاطر هي ان تتحول روبوتات الدردشه
لاداه تحريض على الارهاب صحيفه الجارديان
نقلت عن مسؤول مراجعه تشريعات الارهاب في
بريطانيا قوله ان العالم ركز على ايجابيات
الذكاء الاصطناعي لكنه تجاهل كيفيه
استخدام الارهابيين لهذه التكنولوجيا
لتنفيذ هجمات اعترف المسؤول ان برامج
الدردشه لديها القدره على اقناع الافراد
المتعصبين بشن هجمات ارهابيه وان الاطفال
والمراهقين هما على راس قائمه المستهدفين
فخوره الذكاء الاصطناعي تكمن في امكانيه
الوصول السهل لهؤلاء الشباب حتى داخل غرف
نومهم ما دفع خبراء لا طلاق تحذيرات
بضروره التعلم من دروس الماضي حينما تحولت
منصات التواصل الاجتماعي الى مصدر رئيسي
لتبادل المحتوى الارهابي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات